le plus récent s'est produit en namibie
en novembre 2013
l'enquète conclu que le commandant de
bord a volontairement précipité son
avion flambant neuf dans le désert bilan
33 mans en 1997 en indonésie un boeing
737 de la compagnie silkair plonge dans
une rivière tuant les 104 personnes à
bord
malgré des boîtes noires déconnecter les
enquêteurs américains conclut un geste
intentionnel
quoique une enquête subséquentes parle
plutôt d'une valve défectueuse
mais le cas le plus controversé demeure
celui de la tragédie d'egyptair dans
laquelle deux cent dix sept personnes
ont trouvé la mort en octobre 1999
le boeing 767 s'abîme dans l'atlantique
l'analyse des boîtes noires indiquent
que l'un des pilotes a dit peu avant
l'écrasement et jeu sid
maintenant j'ai pris ma décision je m'en
remets à dieu il s'était retrouvé seul
aux commandes pendant une pause du
commandant de bord pourtant les
autorités égyptiennes ont conclu à une
défaillance mécanique